welcome to this video playing bender
bender from Argentina let's play
something different check Reno Nev I
just want a closed position and then try
to outmaneuver wide let's see if I have
any success with that for let's see h4
okay well I'm going to try to play on
the dark square so I don't really mind
that GM is putting a pawn on h5 I
intended to do those exchanges anyway so
let's get ahead interesting maybe you
felt yeah I wanted to say not exchange
but play 92 well something along these
lines okay I can okay let's let's just
play a play a 6 first so that 95 cannot
disturb it takes I'll just take with the
Queen trying to prove that age 5 is a
weakness
yeah that's a my son strategical
position good good to play against them
more um yeah technically inclined play I
don't know what kind of player the the
white white player he is but if you
think of it's a tournament situation
where you need or you want a game that
is that is really focused on on strategy
and long-term planning then this quite
closed opening can be a very useful tool
people that are very much focused on on
direct technical claim quite often
cannot handle the position simply okay
let's see yeah okay it's me trying to
play g4 to support h5 the question is
should i go G for myself yeah probably
assured just to prevent g-form covering
the pawn I'd like to have a weakness to
attack so if he if I would have allowed
to G for it it's very closed i mean it's
it's certainly ok from like but it's
very closed and this way maybe there is
some some more some more play in the in
the in the position ok 97 and 9-12 6s
what I would lie would like to play 97
though he can take and that that's not
not too great maybe not age of 70 ok on
h6 I just go g6 this is mostly a
weakness then
okay of course it's an important feature
in this position that the bishop only
three is not really doing much yes
that's what that that was a possibility
but I'm trying to use the e5 square now
the question is how exactly do i do that
can go nigh g5 and have six cents 11 way
this is why I wanted to go to d7
originally just to make sure that i can
quickly get to you five but this
shouldn't be bad f6 is just stopping
stopping this right in its tracks yeah
nie jest I just go to h stick then yeah
it's a fairly complicated position but
it's not easy to play for both sides I
just got bit early to lea
is this really happening he's getting
this pawn hmm yeah what did I do wrong I
mean didn't didn't see that at all yeah
it's not even the pawn I mean it's a dig
at least getting rid of her his is weak
Bishop very strange very strange yeah
don't really know something obviously
something I played some some bad stuff
obviously but I don't really know what
it was yeah can I be five is debatable
but it's tough without any sort of play
try to to get some play going yeah a
good one
hmm yeah that's really disappointing I
really thought this was a good position
and then it it somehow turned out to be
nothing at all what the heck did I do
wrong them I had similar positions
before and that was all very nice okay
or hear a threatening g6 now mg6 check
he needs to take that right look h1 and
g7 a half king f7 em chuc so we feel
here he just gave away the rook here
right ok now let's let's check that some
checkmate even
that is that some it is almost make him
don't you don't see one probably i'm
just a complete idiot for not seeing
seeing the win here I don't see it I
don't see it Jim
time warning
yeah this is a really frustrating game I
really it feels like a complete failure
on all accounts I mean I completely
misjudged I need to resign first him
black resign first i played this like
complete idiot yeah because white simply
is worse in this position and then and
then he just blundered it away and I
didn't see it I mean it'sit's I need any
to ever win yeah I'm just a complete
[ __ ] check they have white as winning
the Khamsin so is there no founder
Sanchez he completely overlooked that
that's clear and it's not it's not
winning unbelievable ok King f7 is the
win that King f7 is winning why is it
winning because g6 is the big threat
takes whipped egg sandwich if abject me
yeah king of seven wins yeah there must
be a win because it's just King this
King does not have any squares so it
might it must have been bad but g6 was
wasn't the right one so this wins yeah
Karen gap is just a flat-out win yeah
this is this is the best defense and
this is complete crap music okay now
sometimes you really should get your
brain checked terrible check okay well i
mean this here while i saw a rougarou
group to h5 but i thought this the other
one would would be better but of course
it's not this is just just a simple win
and the second frustrating thing is that
of course why does just just an old play
basically him I mean black is just
better and I didn't I didn't I didn't
conserve this at all maybe a greedy g4
wasn't right it's only good really if I
have
got to get the night 2 235 quickly after
a form and of course the computer is not
understanding the position that's also
quite clear giving giving it as equal I
mean okay maybe it is equal in terms of
white is concerned deal with it but yeah
like as the one calling the shots here
let's call it sets really clear yeah at
night h7 this is this is not really good
job g4s is a weakness in this position
and I don't get I don't get get the the
important things played him maybe I had
to go Knight f6 after all and to deform
and get this get this maneuver in its he
cannot really prevent it cannot really
prevent it and it it does not allow this
this is 96 move yeah i mean i get to e5
without playing f6 yeah yeah and now
amazingly the jeep on drops yeah this I
really misjudged
hmm yeah had the same the store seems
seems okay to me yeah tricky well of
course I didn't I didn't lose the game
at this exact point here at down it
feels like I didn't didn't really find
the right right way to play maybe I
maybe am I must keep it on g5 it's
possible yeah I just made some very
sloppy calculations them to lose it
alright thanks for watching